talk a lot about biology let me ask you
about the Romantic question what role
does Love play in The Human Condition or
in the entirety of life on Earth
it's not easy to learn how to or
have to love if you're not loved
okay so so it's something but the good
news is that it is something that you
can learn I think that's you can
practice uh and and teach yourself how
to maybe give yourself the thing that
wasn't given to you and then ultimately
give it to others I think it would be
quite
arrogant to think that we will be
capable of loving it could be anything
really
um so just like translation it's a
repeating and a dynamical process that
you can learn yeah that you can learn
yes and you should learn we should even
there's no excuse to not learning to
love yeah because that's a deeply human
thing it is a deeply human thing it's it
is a very sad thing if if any one of us
passes this planet without the knowing
what love is and that could be a love to
a pet a love to a plants to a robot
just kidding
um or a fake plant
we love we can't help who we love